sometimes that movie performs so poorly
and become so poisoned by terrible word
of mouth that studios or distributors
will pull it out of theaters abruptly to
end the embarrassment
check out this roundup of box-office
disasters because you probably didn't
see them in theaters Hollywood makes so
many movies out of familiar properties
because name recognition equals free
marketing it's much easier to get film
goers on board with something they
already know than to sell them on a new
concept that's how GI Joe and
transformers became successful movie
franchises ironically though another
fondly remembered cartoon show and toy
line from the 80s became one of the
biggest film flops of all time
Jem and the Holograms a live-action
modernized version of the property about
an all-female rock band opened in
October 2015 and more than 2400 theaters
but the filmmakers didn't stay true to
the source material thus alienating the
only people who'd actually want to go
see it the result was an abysmal rating
on Rotten Tomatoes and an opening
weekend of just 1 point 37 million
dollars in week 2
revenues dropped to a mere three hundred
eighty eight thousand dollars and that's
when Universal pulled it out of theaters
completely and pretended it never even
existed
we were just talking about you yeah we
know we heard everything
inspired by the interactive audiences of
the Rocky Horror Picture Show
screenwriter kim bissell minh conceived
to the film where kids were encouraged
to yell out their thoughts to the
characters on screen the result was the
oh he loves in the big balloon adventure
which was mostly a generic kids movie
with some brightly colored characters
named goobie zoozie and toofie plus
there were special appearances from
stars kids love like Cloris Leachman and
Toni Braxton parents had little interest
in paying for their kids to yell at a
screen for 90 minutes when they could do
that at home for free during its first
weekend the ug loves earned just four
hundred forty eight thousand one hundred
thirty one dollars at over two thousand
theaters accounting for multiple
showings of each location that works out
to an average of about two people per
screening it somehow did even worse in
its next two weekends before the
marketing visionary
that ken bissell minh presents
mercifully removed in june 2015 a movie
with the generic and bland title of
united passions hit theaters
it's a mawkish story of the rise and
greatness of fifa the universally
reviled worldwide governing body of
soccer it's so extremely prophy feh that
it's no surprise the organization
provided most of the film's 22 million
dollar budget it's a bad movie on its
own merits but it also fell victim to
extremely bad timing its release came
just days after the arrests and
indictments of more than a dozen FIFA
executives on corruption charges and the
resignation of FIFA president Sepp
Blatter the director publicly regretted
having made the film and even called it
propaganda United passions played to ten
theaters in the United States where it
earned a grand total of nine hundred
eighteen dollars it then dispassionately
dis unified with theaters after just one
week The Nightmare Before Christmas
isn't the first film to combine scary
Halloween scares with the trappings of
the most wonderful time of the year in
November 1984 Tristar productions
released Silent Night deadly night a
slasher movie in the traditional ad
style but the villain wasn't a guy in a
hockey mask or a knife outfitted glove
instead he was a crazed man named Billy
who killed people with an axe while
dressed as Santa Claus more than 200
picketers assembled at two theaters in
Brooklyn bearing signs that read Santa's
not a hitman and decked the halls with
Holly not bodies that outcry prompted
Tristar to cancel a big TV advertising
push and some theaters refused to book
the movie at all what would have been a
much bigger release wound of a moderate
one as Silent Night deadly night
ultimately played in about 400 theaters
nationwide the outrage killed the film's
prospects like Santa killed his prey and
it was pulled from theaters after two
weeks
[Music]
released in August 1981 honky tonk
freeway is a pleasant enough ensemble
comedy that seems tailor-made to run on
the low wattage local TV station on the
Sunday afternoon it's about a small
Florida tourist trap of a town named T
cloth that's home to a small zoo and a
waterskiing elephant the mayor bribes a
state official to ensure that a new
freeway will include an off-ramp to tea
cloth
thus vastly improving the town's
fortunes the off ramp doesn't get built
so the residents come together to paint
the whole town pink as a publicity stunt
all of that non-action is intercut with
the stories of various individuals about
to wind up in teak law including bank
robbers hitchhikers a family and some
nuns directed by Academy Award winner
John Schlesinger this whole affair
somehow costs twenty four million
dollars six million more than the Empire
Strikes Back the total box office haul
of honky tonk freeway was just over two
million dollars it was gone from
theaters without a trace within a few
weeks in the 2000s lieu of a bowl carved
a niche in the film industry as the
go-to guy to turn video games into
movies even when he lucked into working
with great actors the results remained
of impressive efforts like blood rain
and alone in the dark contributed
heavily to the universally acknowledged
notion that video game movies are always
terrible but one that rises above or
sinks below the rest is postal this 2007
flick took the kilomole action of the
postal games and added a plot in which
the guy who played Farkas at a Christmas
story is the title postal dude the film
includes dozens of gruesome deaths Bowl
playing himself getting shot in the
groin and a supposedly comic scene
lampooning the events of 9/11 not Joe
here while that all seems like the plot
of a direct-to-video movie or possibly a
fever induced nightmare postal somehow
got itself a wide theatrical release
scheduled for May 2008 but just before
its release nearly all of the
distributors that had lined up pulled
out rather than open on 1,500 screens
you know
non-for that's right postal was so bad
that it got pulled out of theaters
before it even arrived had Gigli not
starred two of the biggest celebrities
of the era who were in a high-profile
romance at the time it would have been
just a weird and forgettable movie not a
legendary flop Ben Affleck plays a
stereotypical gangster goon with an
unpronounceable name assigned to kidnap
the Baywatch obsessed developmentally
disabled brother of a federal prosecutor
things go awry so the bosses send in a
more capable operative Ricky played by
Jennifer Lopez then the two fall in love
even though Ricky is gay and G Lee is a
raging misogynist that plot and the
off-screen Bennifer antics led to an
unofficial competition among critics
over who could say the meanest things in
their reviews The Wall Street Journal
called it the worst movie all right
the worst allegedly major movie of our
admittedly young century somehow G Lee
cost fifty four million dollars to make
but it unsurprisingly bummed bringing in
just six million dollars after three
weeks in theaters it moved to its final
resting place in the grocery-store DVD
bargain Benz Madonna is certainly one of
the greatest and most influential pop
stars of all time that goodwill has very
little to do with her fur Ray's into
acting she's basically the Meryl Streep
of the Razzie Awards the Oscars of bad
movies have dishonored Madonna a
remarkable 16 times for stinkers like
Shanghai surprise body of evidence and
swept away the last one seemed like it
might be a little better than the usual
Madonna movie as it was written and
directed by Guy Ritchie
he's the acclaimed filmmaker behind Lock
Stock and Two Smoking Barrels who also
happened to be Madonna's husband at the
time that didn't seem to do much good
however the desert island rom-com
suffered a critical drubbing and took
home four Razzies audiences didn't like
it either it played in American theaters
for three weekends to a total of less
than $600,000 before the distributor
swept it away in the late 2000s a
science fiction allegory about
respecting nature and the dangers of
colonialism hit theaters it utilized
cutting-edge CGI and anime
technology to render lifelike but exotic
humanoid creatures but we're not
actually talking about avatar which
pulled in a record 2.7 billion dollars
at the worldwide box office and played
back movie theaters for months on end
nope this is the story of delgo a movie
at the other end of the box-office
spectrum with the protagonists fleeing
their resource ravaged homeland for
another this 2008 animated feature pour
a similar look and premise to avatar but
it had far from the same success made by
the small fathom Studios development
began in 1999 when CGI animation was
still something of a novelty by the time
of its release in 2008 delgo style was
old hat and not particularly well
executed plus its lead voice actors
Freddie Prinze jr. and Jennifer Love
Hewitt had lost their a list status
while avatar broke just about every box
office record Delco broke one too it
earned five hundred eleven thousand
dollars at 2160 theaters during its
first weekend bad enough to make it the
worst wide release opening weekend ever
at the time it doesn't rank among the
worst second weekend's of all time
though because freestyle releasing a
delgo out of theaters just seven days
after its release